well i i i i agree with you because
women leave more but i also think it
goes back to like the consequences thing
like are men more forgiving or do they
have to be because there's more
consequences for them not because if
they leave they might lose half their
[ __ ]
i think when a woman leaves she's done
like when a woman leaves she's done i
think she was done saying she's done
something at the time she was done six
months before
at the very minimum we're done two weeks
before the end of the relationship
bare minimum literally yeah okay so the
question becomes why are so many women
saying that they're done nowadays why
because we're fed up with being we're
figuring out
the illusion of choice
do you know what i think it is i think
women were sold out why is it an
illusion
i think i think it's the syndrome of the
grass is always greener no but probably
always but yeah
is that grass no no no it's the guys
it's the small percentage of guys that
can do that that do i think it's not
it's not the majority of men because the
majority like one in three men under 30
are a virgin
i'm telling you it's not you know what
y'all be safe you know what i think
women were sold a lie they were sold the
hollywood dream of what a relationship
was they were so the disney dream of
what a relationship the notebook and
then what happens is when they get into
these relationships they realize oh this
is this is not what it was this is not
what it's supposed to be and they leave
men i think are more realistic which is
why it's women who most of the time who
are initiating divorces
i would say this though
sorry let me just say this point why is
it that women the knowledge of hollywood
tells that women can all be princesses
that means you've got gotta be um um
but you're not
so the fact that
hollywood tells you oh you're a princess
but the definition of a princess i'm a
queen
but i also think it's supply and demand
right i think men probably would leave
more if they felt like they could leave
and get someone better no because men
when men find out when men choose the
woman that they're going to be with
if they say i do men generally
this is me
this is me for like all right cool i'm
fine this is me for life i'm good right
a lot of women hypergamy comes into
play right and they're like ah you know
what maybe i can get something better
than this because uh
and really and truly
once you divorce a man
and you've got a couple of children
it's not looking like what you think
it's going to be looking like once you
leave that guy it's not it's what you've
created in your head and that perfect
relationship that you're going to get
yeah i mean i think that's right maybe
in that instance but i think in the
beginning stage when you're when you're
dating men are
more reluctant to commit in the
beginning because they they do think the
grass is greener but then what tends to
happen is they get a partner and they're
like i'm not sure i'm on the fence
and then whatever it ends and then they
realize that a couple months i'm like oh
actually the the grass isn't is it
my experience yeah the knowledge i like
to use is chewing gum it tastes good for
throw up after this sugar comes out you
spit it out
so you spit me out no i'm just sitting
there no no no you're waiting have you
guys no um like the like the streets the
streets aren't that great basically i
just want to ask have any of you guys
started watching the ultimatum on
netflix yes
so it's basically a show about couples
um i i don't know how many couples there
are like maybe like eight of them let's
say
and one of the partners in the couple
gives them an ultimatum it's you have to
marry me now or i leave now
and
in the process they get to date all
these other people within these other
couples so like let's say you and i were
together and you two were together
[Music]
i could go and date him and you can go
date him
and you wouldn't date manchester
yeah you're right
um
and if we end up vibing enough and we
both feel like this relationship is
worth it i can go ahead and leave him
and we get married instead yeah just
because the ultimatum was not met by my
original partner yeah so i did a show
yeah on marriage and i think marriage
has become a joke
and that actually that show i've never
seen it but it actually shows that
marriage has become a joke because
marriage is now a tv show
people don't give a damn
is a joke and this is one of the reasons
or it's maybe a symptom of the fact that
marriage is not being taken seriously we
can we can now make a reality tv show
out but i think the problem is that the
standard of marriage has changed so many
times like marriage initially started
off as
here's my daughter give me a dowry yeah
the only difference like i really think
it's just the takeaway of consequence
because we added birth control that
changed marriage forever because you
take away the consequence of like
getting pregnant and like dating so
before like you had to get married
younger otherwise like how many women
started getting rights as well like we
didn't need to marry a man in order to
have a bank account or be able to do any
sort of thing with finances as well but
most of the time women ended up in these
marriages because we needed something
you know yeah are you a feminist
why does that matter no i'm just asking
because you're speaking like a feminist
no i'm speaking about history yeah but
i'm awesome if you don't know basic
history
that doesn't make me a feminist it just
means that i think everybody says
the feminists have delivered equality
feminists have the legitimate complaint
but the wrong solution mm-hmm yeah
yeah yeah that's why i would say what
happened yeah feminism yeah
because there was a legitimate complaint
like for example you couldn't open a
bank account without your husband's
right approval for example the divorce
laws was if there was a divorce in the
same 18 1700s this is why agree with the
feminists
everything went to the man
so obviously there had to be a pen and
obviously that caused resentment and
that's what caused that reaction that's
where you had the sub-rejects movement
and stuff but obviously now it's gone
well it's gone well it's gone way over
like that so in the same way i sort of
agree and i just said this to you a few
months back that uh in some ways i do
agree with the alumni rules in principle
in the sense that it's the man no no no
let me let me explain i can see let me
let me explain let me explain okay i was
initially ex
initiated because if a whoop if a man
did leave a woman the woman was
obviously destitute so they've put this
law in place to think okay if the man
decides to do the ultimate thing and
leave a woman the woman doesn't become
obviously different how do we get to
them
now but now it's gone
no it's gone way overboard because i
think their initial role there was a
good logic behind it
because now divorce is a business to you
you can marry into you can marry a man
yeah the the height the most the richest
women in america are divorcees
it's a business divorce is a business
sometimes i think that like
i put this there should be no laws
around it at all and like like around
marriage yeah like
like we just make it a business like
like like take the government out of it
completely
because like i feel like everyone just
has to deal with their own consequences
so like if you pick someone that's going
to leave you the second like why don't
you say the government out of it because
the government needs to register who's
getting married so they can make good
choices in terms of building
infrastructure when they're doing census
and stuff so that needs to be government
needs to be involved okay like can't you
do it without the legal ramifications
like there's no
no i can definitely agree with that yeah
like because now women can work like i
said right that's the thing like at
least i can speak for america because i
can't speak for other countries one
thing about america they're gonna make
everything a business and they've
managed to make it
they managed to make capitalism marriage
a business
they managed to make colleges a business
like they
i don't know they're just the kings of
that [ __ ] i can't say much about that
but
you know they can see that they can take
some money out of that they're like oh
your joint household income is so and so
when you guys are married this is your
marital status perfect we'll take out
these taxes like oh you have how many
kids together
this is what we're going to take out of
this like
bring back incentive if you get married
you get tax break of a hundred grand
a hundred grand
you don't pay no time
i just say rework the relationship model
because the current one is not working
nah i don't i don't like the three years
i'm feeling like that ain't working for
me i'm here you hang on you think i'm
help as much as you know
about the manuscript much as you know
about statistics about divorce and right
you think that this is to get rid of
workers no i said get rid of the laws
like why why do we need alimony why do
we need like do we need all that i need
to bring up it should have been already
obvious that someone would have their
own [ __ ] and you have your own but
there's a there's like there's
there's a difference i think between
like
see that's hard because i do i could see
prenups because that's something you
agree to like beforehand right right
yeah but
okay so but that should be standard from
the start hello you know the statistics
right yeah you know marriages are not
working they're breaking down
right well you know what i think though
i think like marriage didn't necessarily
work before i think we just have more
opportunity to leave because how many
grandparents were separated that was
really common like people say oh it was
a different generation
but my grandparents were separated they
were married they were married for a
very long time but they were and i i
could say like that's so common so now
what's the solution then what's the
right because if i see certain things
going a certain way i'm like okay cool
how can we fix that yeah yeah yeah he's
like
the light before and there's the lights
out we're gonna fix that yeah so i'm
saying the current model clearly isn't
working right okay it's not it's not
working we will agree yeah right okay so
do we need a new model are we gonna
stick with the old model
i i
[Music]
i was going to bring it back to what
pearl said regardless a lot of people
just stayed in marriage just because
it's easier than leaving it's convenient
especially um when you're bringing
religion to it right like christians
they don't believe in divorce at least
hardcore christians don't believe in
divorce
some christians do believe in the world
that's why i said hardcore christians
when you're when you're going into like
orthodox yeah so same thing with uh
possibly but now the question is is that
a bad thing because it's every study is
gonna tell you that it's better for
children to have both parents in the
home you put your kid at every
statistical disadvantage if you don't
have both parents in the home
so is it is it necessarily a bad thing
if it's if i think it's better off for
the parents to be separated i could be
biased just because i came from a
divorced parent household but it is much
better than letting your kids sit there
and watch two parents who don't love
each other anymore whether the storm
just for them and then the child grows
up thinking that they're the burden
like it happens very often no love is
always sacrificial it's not about what
you'll feel yeah but if you're if you
don't love anymore then when did your
parents get divorced love is not a
feeling it was just the mistakes that
we're making i was about seven years old
you're about seven love isn't action
love is not a feeling what do you think
about that
if love is an action
if we started seeing it as an action not
so much a feeling do you think would be
in this world people cannot weather
those storms though a lot of people are
weak i hate to say it some people do not
have the strength to stay in the same
household as their partners
i disagree because like i said if i'm
married with the kids there's some days
i don't feel like going to work
can i say to my family i don't feel like
going to work today this stuff but
that's why i do it because i've got a
greater goal beauty duty no i i like i
agree with you because it's not why i
just feel like once you have because
people always ask me would i stay with
the cheater and i always say no unless
there were kids because once you have
kids it's not about you i can totally
understand that however because i don't
have children i cannot make that
right you know comment right but what i
can say is from the perspective of
somebody who you said
even though you didn't have children
right huh you said you were cheating
even though you didn't have when i was
17 right that's the difference here you
got to understand
you know i
grew up watching people cheat on each
other all the time okay so i'm thinking
like oh so yeah that might that must
happen
exactly my perception was skewed on that
however i started to grow up a little
bit more and i started to mature a
little bit more and understand this is
not how it's supposed to be
right cheating should not be normalized
and like i said when it comes to parents
staying together i think my parents
tried their absolute hardest to stay
together for me mm-hmm but i was seeing
a lot more
no i have two siblings okay okay um i
think sometimes but they're
significantly younger than me and
they're both half siblings like sorry
there's one from my mom's side and one
for my dad's side so they don't have to
deal with what i dealt with growing up
they're actually watching a happy
relationship or marriage now and i would
much rather prefer that they deal with
that like i'm happy i think sometimes
what trips us up is our definition what
love is in greek i think it has the best
it has some great definition you have
eros
othello
and agape agape is the sacrificial love
it's the love that doesn't expect
african return the closest one that we
can have from a human perspective is the
love our mother has for a child
but scripturally scripture says when the
husband's supposed to love his wife
you're supposed to guard pet your wife
love you know unconditionally
in a way that um sacrificially even
though she's not returning it back to
you you you need to give that and i
think if people more focused on that
that might in my culture we call that
idiot
maybe maybe but maybe that may solve
some issues but both parties have to do
that i think that's what i'm just trying
to get for this notion you don't love
somebody
if it's not returned
that's a fella but that's not the love
you're meant to have for y'all
i think everybody has different
standards and definition of love and
what sounds like that for your child but
not for your
it's not dependent on feelings or
if it's reciprocal that's the
sacrificial of you meant to have that's
what i'm saying scripturally for a woman
you're supposed to have sacrificial love
for for your wife yes that's christ is
the wife supposed to have sacrificial
love for husbands yes
supposedly
yeah this is what i'm saying it's not
about feelings this is why i hate this
notion of i am in love with someone i'm
out of luck with someone that's it's so
mixed up it's so
so populish we see this in the soap
operas we think oh we're going to do it
it's disney stuff yeah disney stuff yeah
yeah loves always a duty
yeah but i just think that's like
there's until a certain point i do think
i i'm and i'm i think it's rare but i
think there are some instances where
like
you should leave like your wife gaining
150 pounds
my goodness cause then you know what
because you know what that's child abuse
because then you're teaching your kids
so you wouldn't have obesity
obesity
yes
sorry
look at look at because that's child
abuse you raise your kid in an
environment where you're teaching them
to be obese
child abuse sorry it's that you're
giving them horrible habits the rest of
their life
still hungry
yeah it's probably because you're wrong
okay i'm going to read you call me
i'm gonna read super